Cô quan lý và sây dựng công trình thuy lợi, bố nông nghiệp và môi trường, tính đến mười bày dựng ngày mười bốn thằng sau,
mưa lơn só anh rưởng của báo số một đá gây ngập uống gần sau mấy bà nghiênhec ta dịch sản xuất nông nghiệp tại khu vực trùng bộ.
Tại bác trùng bộ, tổng dịch tích bị anh rưởng hơn bốm ít tư nghìn năm 2018, trong đó thử thiên mế hơn mười bà nghiênhec ta,
khoảng chỉ người chiến nhìn 2018, khoảng viên bệnh nghiệp 1,5 mỡ hách ta và hả tính sau trong mề hách ta.
Cô vực năm Trung bộ có hơn mề tắm nhìn 2018 dâu mộ và dịch nuôi trồng thuy sản đi ngập tất trung trủ yếu ở đảnh và khoảng năm.
Cuyện các địa phương đã vẫn hành bệnh mấy trả bân, công tiêu nhằm tiêu uống bảo vệ sản xuất.
Dung tích các hồ chứ tại khu vực bác vật năm Trung bộ tăng sau với ngày 1 tằng sau,
ra động từ bố mấy sau phần chăm đến chiếm mấy sau, phần chăm dung tích khi tế.
Một số hồ lớn như cửa đặt, ai từ nước trong xong cái đăng xả trảnh đều tiết lúc.
Bộ nông nghiệp và môi trường yêu cầu các địa phương tiếp tục trực bán nghiêm tức, vẫn hành hồ chữa ăn quan.
Thà giỏi sát tình yên ngưu, bảo đam ăn quan công chiến và vùng hả dù, chù đậu bảo vệ sản xuất, đời sống nhân dân.